so während sich andere parteien nur noch
digital treffen aus feigheit vor dem
virus veranstaltet die afg einen präsenz
parteitag mit über 600 delegierten in
kalkar ein bisschen aus wie die
schulklasse aus der hölle
wobei die meisten schlagzeilen danach
auch nicht wirklich fair waren tief
gespaltene afd zerlegt sich selbst also
in erster linie freunde war das richtig
gute unterhaltung
davon dürfte gerne mehr im fernsehen
laufen wir können nicht einfach die
leute die ihre zeit und nach die ist
vorbei
seid ihr denn des wahnsinns
darüber ist wirklich mein held hat
wirklich fast geblutet dankeschön jetzt
bei rtl hält island afb noch niveauloser
als das sommerhaus der stars
[Musik]
dafür würde ich sogar zwangsgebühren
zahlen
grüße nach magdeburg eigentlich wollte
die afg vor allem über ihr erstes
rentenkonzept reden was achtung ganz
okay es in teil
selbstständige und politiker sollen zum
beispiel auch ein zahlen interessiert
aber kein wegen der schrei agiert was
war passiert jörg merten hatte als
vorsitzender plötzlich herausgefunden
dass seine eigene partei in teilen
irgendwie rechts ist und das hat einer
brandrede auch einfach mal angesprochen
hier eine reaktion aus der basis gerne
da für dich sagt morton und findet
außerdem wir werden nicht mehr erfolg
erzielen indem wir immer aggressiver
immer der aber immer enthemmter
auftreten so geht das nicht
klar geht das was redet der antifa manda
jahre lang ging das super immer
enthemmter immer derber bei der
markenkern der afd
mit klarer aufgabenteilung er hier
professor morgen ist die bürgerliche
fassade und die völkischen hardliner
rund um herrn röcke ziehen im
hintergrund die fäden ne oder versuchen
verzweifelt sich wie gerade an die
querdenker bewegung dranzuhängen weil
selbst komplett geisteskranker
querdenker widerstand ist ja irgendwo
widerstand dieses bekenntnis zum
widerstand das ist auch ein bisschen
sexy wir müssen es sexy werden würde
jetzt fast sagen ja und nicht auf den
knien daherkommen ii sexy auf den knien
kopfkino in kalkar sind die beiden
partei helfen tatsächlich mal frontal
aufeinander gescheppert alter haben sich
die hecke leute über den morden
aufgeregt denn der professor hat in
seiner skandal rede nicht nur über
querdenker gelöst hat sondern ich mag
das kaum aussprechen über reichskanzler
bismarck einige in unseren reihen
scheinen darunter ein zurück ins gestern
zu verstehen sich bei bismarck zu hause
gestern hatten am ende auch noch
bismarck angegriffen ich bin großer fan
des reichskanzlers von bismarck
ich hätte zum beispiel die bismarck
kritischen worte weggelassen
ich bin auch ein bewunderer von bismarck
in dem unsere unserem schwächer herrn
professor mutter stellt wird er hätte in
irgendeiner art und weise die leistung
des reichskanzlers von bismarck
herabgewürdigt dem angriff hervor der
umgedrehten das geht nicht
ja die afg hat einfach ein gespür für
zukunftsthemen bismarck als nächstes
setzen sie sich wahrscheinlich über
ramses den dritten aber schon
interessant wenn ich jetzt wo man weiß
dass bismarck für die quasi heilig ist
eröffnen sich natürlich ganz neue witz
möglichkeiten ausgezeichnet
otto von bismarck mit abstand der
unfähigste deutsche politiker aller
zeiten noch voran die scheuer
der typ hat ja wirklich gar nichts auf
die kette kriegt goodbye charta ist sein
hering ganz okay und der hat den helm
mit pixar erfunden geschenkt aber sonst
der von ihm erfundene korn macht grauen
auf den kopfschmerzen und was ist mit
der bismarck basiert genau hätte man den
kam bloß anders genannt
bismarck totaler verbessere selbst
sascha hehn ist mit mehr würde von bord
gegangen
kurz gesagt fürst bismarck was für ein
auto
[Musik]
absoluter otto leuten hat übrigens lange
wunderbar mit höcker und co
zusammengearbeitet
jetzt hat er offensichtlich schiss weil
der verfassungsschutz ab dem nächsten
jahr die gesamtpartei beobachten könnte
in brandenburg zum beispiel passiert das
schon da setzt der verfassungsschutz hat
er gerade bestätigt v-leute 1 in der
partei normalerweise wissen sie sehr
scheue gesellen
aber wir haben heute tatsächlich einen
da abdel karim wurde vor jahren in die
brandenburger afd eingeschleust wie sind
ihre erfahrungen
ich hatte viele einblicke war aber auch
ganz einfach die dachten alle ich bin
der bruder von attila hildmann und ich
war jetzt auch als v mann bei einem
parteitag in kalkar dabei man ist er
heute froh wenn man überhaupt mal raus
kommt also klar war jetzt ein sehr
lauter parteitag aber dafür war das
buffet gut es gab sogar mit brötchen
oder wie wir das nennen mit brüchen wie
viel sinn macht die beobachtung der afg
für sie das war ehrlich gesagt was gibt
es da zu beobachten für die afg brauche
ich keine v leute da reicht wenn ich den
parteitag auf phoenix gruppe dann sehe
ich ganz klar eine hälfte des
verbitterten ex cdu was die anderen sind
rechtsextreme querdenker oder
rechtsextreme querdenker ende der
beobachtung na ja immer ein paar
innenminister von spd und cdu haben
gerade schon wieder die verbot debatte
eröffnet die blut sind ich meine ein
größeres geschenk kann man der afg doch
gar nicht machen die leben von der
opferrolle das sind quasi gelernte opfer
im gegenteil wenn man die afg ärgern
möchte dann muss man sie loben also sagt
man mensch ein neues rentenkonzept gar
nicht schlecht da soll noch beamte
einzahlen super oder eure idee mit der
neuen windel steuer fordern wir heute
wenigstens die mehrwertsteuer für
babywindeln auf sieben prozent zu
reduzieren
damit wollen wir die diskriminierung von
babys beenden
dies ist wichtiger als ihre
feministische tampon subvention neben
dem mann sind am terror zieht ja alles
runter studium ich bin als traum mal
einfach zu lange dabei haben die afg
fordert sogar ein baby begrüßungsgeld um
die geburtenrate hoch zu peitschen
10.000 euro darlehen pro baby wer hätte
das gedacht die afg fördert arabische
großfamilien und jetzt kommt der knaller
ab dem dritten kind muss man das baby
nicht mehr zurück sein man kann den
kredit also quasi ab knapp h
für die geburtenrate das erklärt
natürlich auch deren neues plakat hfd
fick dich deutschland jetzt macht das
sind natürlich aber wir wollen das ganze
auch nicht verniedlichen teile der afd
wollen die parlamentarische demokratie
weg haben es ist so erkennt man auch
daran wie die sich im bundestag benehmen
sogar in der kantine ein mitarbeiter der
afg fraktion oder eines fdp-abgeordneten
nimmt war das ein anderer ein
vegetarisches gericht bestellt darauf
kommt die bemerkung euch kriegen wir
auch noch ihr körnerfresser war gut wer
vegetarier wird hat aber auch ein
stückweit produziert ja natürlich sind
die verfassungsfeinde dabei aber wenn
ich den laden verbiete bleiben die fans
und die ansichten ja trotzdem muss man
mit leben auch das ist deutschland
deutschland sieht nicht nur so aus wie
ich okay und nun v leute bringen auch
nix
ich meine die heute show hat ja auch
ganz offensichtlich einen v mann in der
afg von nordrhein westfalen und das hat
sich voll ausgezahlt
hier original presseeinladung nicht von
uns bearbeitet
hiermit möchte ich sie informieren doch
der landessprecher der ard nrw in höxter
gemeinsam mit dem landessprecher der afg
thüringen herrn bernd höcker auftreten
wird geil oder was daran lustig so heißt
doch abdel karim
ja it-service bruns ich spreche mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung